ยินดีต้อนรับกลับมาสู่ Understanding Quantum Information and Computation ผมชื่อ John Watus และผมเป็นผู้อำนวยการด้านเทคนิคฝ่ายการศึกษาที่ IBM
Quantum นี่คือบทเรียนที่ 14 ของซีรีส์ และเป็นบทเรียนที่สองของหน่วยที่สี่ ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ Quantum error
correction ในบทเรียนก่อนหน้า เราได้ดู Quantum error correction เป็นครั้งแรก รวมถึง nine qubit Shore code ซึ่งพิสูจน์ว่า
Quantum error correction เป็นไปได้ในทางทฤษฎี เรายังได้พูดถึง discretization of errors ซึ่งทำให้เรา
สามารถแก้ไข Quantum error ต่างๆ บน qubit ได้ โดยการ project มันลงบน bit flip และ phase
flip ในบทเรียนนี้เราจะพูดถึง stabilizer formalism ซึ่งเป็นเครื่องมือทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่เราสามารถใช้
ระบุและวิเคราะห์ quantum error correcting code กลุ่มกว้างที่เรียกว่า stabilizer code ซึ่งรวมถึง 9 qubit Shore
code รวมถึงตัวอย่างอื่นๆ อีกมากมาย รวมถึง code ที่น่าจะเหมาะกับอุปกรณ์ Quantum
Computing ในโลกจริงมากกว่า Shore code ไม่ใช่ทุก quantum error correcting code จะเป็น stabilizer code แต่หลายตัวเป็น
รวมถึงทุกตัวอย่างที่เราจะเห็นในซีรีส์นี้ แน่นอนว่ามี quantum error
correcting code ที่น่าสนใจและอาจมีประโยชน์ที่ไม่ใช่ stabilizer code แต่พวกมันมักจะซับซ้อนกว่ามาก และไม่ว่ายังไงก็ไม่มี
ข้อสงสัยว่า stabilizer formalism เป็นรากฐานสำคัญของ quantum error correction และเราจะ
พึ่งพามันอย่างมากสำหรับส่วนที่เหลือของหน่วยนี้ นี่คือภาพรวมสั้นๆ ของบทเรียน เราจะเริ่มด้วยการพูดคุยสั้นๆ
เกี่ยวกับ Pauli matrix และ tensor product ของ Pauli matrix ซึ่งสามารถแทนทั้ง operation บน qubit รวมถึง
measurement ของ qubit ตามที่ผมจะอธิบาย และในบริบทนี้เรามักเรียกมันว่า observable จากนั้นเราจะกลับไปดู
repetition code อีกครั้ง และเราจะเห็นว่าเราสามารถอธิบายมันผ่าน Pauli operation และ observable ได้ยังไง และนั่นจะให้ข้อมูล
และนำไปสู่การพูดคุยทั่วไปเกี่ยวกับ stabilizer code รวมถึงตัวอย่างหลายอัน คุณสมบัติพื้นฐานของ stabilizer
code และวิธีที่เราสามารถทำงานพื้นฐานอย่างการ encode การตรวจจับ error และการแก้ไข
error เราจะเริ่มบทเรียนด้วยการพูดคุยสั้นๆ เกี่ยวกับ Pauli operation ส่วนใหญ่เพื่อปูทางสำหรับ
stabilizer formalism แต่ก็เพื่อสังเกตข้อเท็จจริงสำคัญบางอย่างและตั้งศัพท์พื้นฐาน อันดับแรก นี่คือ Pauli
matrix รวมถึง identity matrix ขนาด 2x2 รวมถึง non-identity Pauli matrix สามตัว ซึ่งเราจะแทนด้วย
X Y และ Z ตลอดส่วนที่เหลือของซีรีส์ matrix ทั้งสี่ตัวนี้เป็นทั้ง unitary และ Hermitian และเราสามารถ
เชื่อมโยงมันกับ operation บน qubit รวมถึง operation ที่เราอาจเลือกทำ รวมถึง error ตามที่เรา
พูดถึงในบทเรียนก่อนหน้า non-identity Pauli matrix X Y และ Z anticommute กัน
หมายความว่า XY เท่ากับ -1 คูณ YX, XZ เท่ากับลบ ZX และ YZ เท่ากับ
ลบ ZY และสามารถตรวจสอบความสัมพันธ์เหล่านี้ได้ง่ายๆ โดยการคูณ ความสัมพันธ์ anti-commutation
เหล่านี้เรียบง่ายมาก แต่สำคัญอย่างยิ่งใน stabilizer formalism และที่อื่นๆ และโดยเฉพาะ
อย่างที่เราจะเห็น เครื่องหมายลบที่โผล่ออกมาเมื่อเราสลับลำดับของ non-identity Pauli matrix สองตัวที่ต่างกันในผลคูณ จะตรงกับ
การตรวจจับ error ใน stabilizer formalism พอดี เรายังมีกฎการคูณที่แสดงไว้ตรงนี้
Pauli matrix แต่ละตัวเป็น inverse ของตัวเอง ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับความจริงที่ว่ามันเป็นทั้ง unitary และ Hermitian และถ้าคูณ non-identity
Pauli matrix สองตัวที่ต่างกันเข้าด้วยกัน จะได้บวกหรือลบ i คูณ non-identity
Pauli matrix ตัวที่เหลือเสมอ โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าไม่สนใจ global phase แล้ว Y เทียบเท่ากับ X คูณ Z ซึ่งอธิบายว่าทำไมเราถึงโฟกัสที่ X และ Z error ใน
quantum error correction X แทน bit flip, Z แทน phase flip ดังนั้นถ้าไม่สนใจ global phase แล้ว Y แทน
error ทั้งสองอันที่เกิดขึ้นบน qubit เดียวกัน matrix ทั้งสี่ตัวนี้แทน
operation หรือ error หรือการไม่มี error บน qubit เดียว แต่มันมักจะสะดวกที่จะ tensor มันเข้าด้วยกัน
เพื่อทำ operation หรือ error บนหลาย qubit ในแง่ของศัพท์ เมื่อเราพูดถึง n qubit Pauli
operation เราหมายถึง tensor product ของ Pauli matrix n ตัว เช่นตัวอย่างที่แสดง
ตรงนี้ มันก็เป็นเรื่องปกติที่จะใช้คำว่า Pauli operation เมื่อมี global phase ด้วย แต่เพื่อให้ง่ายที่สุด
ผมจะใช้คำว่า Pauli operation ในความหมายแค่ tensor product ของ Pauli matrix น้ำหนักของ n qubit Pauli
operation ก็คือจำนวน non-identity Pauli matrix ใน tensor product ตัวอย่างเช่น tensor product n ชั้น
ของ identity matrix ขนาด 2x2 กับตัวเอง คือ Pauli operation น้ำหนักศูนย์ tensor product ของ Pauli X
matrix สองตัว กับ identity matrix อีกหลายตัว มีน้ำหนักสอง และต่อไปเรื่อยๆ โดยสัญชาตญาณ น้ำหนักของ n
qubit Pauli operation คือจำนวน qubit ที่มัน act อย่างไม่ trivial และมันเป็นเรื่องปกติที่ quantum error correcting code จะถูก
ออกแบบให้ตรวจจับและแก้ไข error ที่แทนด้วย Pauli operation ได้จนถึงน้ำหนักหนึ่ง เราสามารถ
คิดเกี่ยวกับ Pauli operation ในหลายแบบ รวมถึงเป็น operation ที่ทำโดยตั้งใจผ่าน quantum gate รวมถึง
error และเราจะเห็นในไม่ช้าว่า Pauli operation สามารถอธิบาย measurement ได้ด้วย บางครั้งก็มีประโยชน์
ที่จะคิดถึง Pauli operation ในฐานะ generator ของเซตบางอย่างในเชิงพีชคณิต ซึ่งอาจคุ้นเคยถ้า
รู้จัก group theory ถ้าไม่คุ้นเคยกับ group theory ก็ไม่เป็นไร มันไม่จำเป็นจริงๆ
สำหรับบทเรียนนี้ แต่ถ้าสนใจศึกษา quantum error correction ในเชิงลึกมากขึ้น อาจจะพบว่า
group theory พื้นฐานมีประโยชน์มาก อย่างไรก็ตาม สมมติว่า P1 ถึง PR เป็น n qubit Pauli operation
P1 เป็น n qubit Pauli operation, P2 เป็น n qubit Pauli operation และต่อไปเรื่อยๆ เมื่อเราพูดถึงเซตที่ generate โดย
P1 ถึง PR เราหมายถึงเซตของ matrix ทั้งหมดที่ได้จากการคูณ matrix เหล่านี้เข้าด้วยกันใน
ทุกๆ combination และทุกลำดับที่เราเลือก โดยเอาแต่ละตัวกี่ครั้งก็ได้ เราจะเห็นตัวอย่างบางอันในอีกสักครู่
แต่ก่อนอื่น ให้ผมบอก notation ที่เราใช้แทนเซตนี้ เซตที่ generate โดย P1 ถึง PR และ
มันคือ P1 ถึง PR คั่นด้วยเครื่องหมายจุลภาค ในวงเล็บเหลี่ยม มันดูเหมือนจะสับสนกับ
Dirac notation ได้ง่าย แต่โดยทั่วไปไม่ค่อยเกิดขึ้น และนี่คือ notation แบบดั้งเดิมใน group
theory นี่คือตัวอย่างของเซตที่ generate โดย X Y และ Z ดังนั้น n เท่ากับหนึ่งในตัวอย่างนี้ เพราะไม่มี
tensor product และเราใช้ non-identity Pauli matrix ทั้งสามตัวเป็น generator ปรากฏว่ามี
16 matrix ที่สามารถ generate ได้จากการคูณ matrix สามตัวนี้ และสามารถหาเหตุผลได้
ผ่านกฎการคูณที่เราเห็นก่อนหน้า โดยเฉพาะ เราสามารถได้ X Y และ Z รวมถึง identity
และจริงๆ แล้ว เราสามารถได้ matrix ทั้งสี่ตัวนี้คูณด้วย i, 1 หรือลบ i และนั่นคือ
ทั้งหมดนี้ เซตนี้เป็นที่รู้จักกันทั่วไปว่า Pauli group เราสามารถพิจารณาเซตที่
generate โดยแค่ X และ Z แล้วเราจะได้ครึ่งหนึ่งของ Pauli group ในกรณีนี้
และตัวอย่างสุดท้ายอย่างน้อยตอนนี้ เราสามารถพิจารณาเซตที่ generate โดย X tensor X และ Z tensor Z ดังนั้น n เท่ากับ
สองในกรณีนี้ และเราได้แค่สี่ element คราวนี้ เนื่องจาก X tensor X และ Z tensor Z
commute กัน Pauli matrix และ n qubit Pauli operation โดยทั่วไป อธิบาย
unitary operation ไม่ว่าจะเป็น error หรือตั้งใจ แต่มันยังอธิบาย
measurement ด้วย ถ้าจะพูดให้แม่นยำขึ้น เริ่มจากแค่ non-identity Pauli matrix สามตัว เราสามารถเชื่อมโยง matrix แต่ละตัว
กับ projective measurement ที่นิยามโดย eigenvalue และ eigenvector ของมัน และบนจอเรา
มี spectral decomposition ของ matrix เหล่านี้ที่จะช่วยอธิบายเรื่องนี้ โดยหลักแล้ว เมื่อเราพูดถึง X
measurement, Y measurement หรือ Z measurement เราหมายถึง projective measurement ที่นิยามโดย projection
ลงบน eigenspace ของ matrix เหล่านี้ และโดยทั่วไปเราคิดว่า eigenvalue เป็น
measurement outcome ที่สอดคล้องกัน ตัวอย่างเช่น X measurement คือ measurement ในเทอมของ plus
minus basis ของ qubit หรืออีกแบบหนึ่ง เราสามารถอธิบายมันด้วยเซตที่มี projection ket plus bra plus และ ket
minus bra minus Z measurement นั้นก็แค่ standard basis
measurement แม้ว่าอย่างที่พูดไป บางครั้งเราเชื่อมโยง eigenvalue กับ measurement outcome และถ้าทำอย่างนั้น
outcome จะเป็นบวกหนึ่งและลบหนึ่ง แทนที่จะเป็น 0 และ 1 ตามลำดับ จริงๆ แล้วเราสามารถทำอะไร
ในทำนองนี้กับ Hermitian matrix ใดๆ และคำว่า observable ก็ใช้กันทั่วไปในสถานการณ์นี้ สำหรับ Pauli
matrix และ n qubit Pauli operation โดยทั่วไป เราสามารถทำ measurement แบบนี้อย่าง non-destructive โดยใช้
phase estimation และเพื่อให้แน่ใจว่า diagram นี้ชัดเจน เราทำ measurement อย่าง non-destructive บน
qubit บน ส่วน qubit ล่างจะถูก initialize เป็น plus state เสมอ หรือพูดอีกแบบคือ Hadamard ที่ใช้กับ
zero state เพราะนั่นคือวิธีที่ phase estimation ทำงาน สังเกตว่าเพราะ eigenvalue
เป็นแค่บวกหนึ่งและลบหนึ่งในกรณีนี้ เราต้องการแค่ control qubit เดียว ซึ่งก็คือ qubit ล่างใน
diagram นี้ มากกว่านั้นจะเปลืองเปล่า เพราะมีแค่หนึ่ง bit ของ precision ที่ต้องกังวล eigenvalue
เป็นบวกหนึ่งหรือลบหนึ่ง และ measurement ก็ perfect อยู่แล้วแบบนี้ outcome ของ measurement นี้
ก็คือ standard basis measurement ใน circuit จะเป็นศูนย์สำหรับ eigenvalue outcome บวกหนึ่ง
ซึ่งตรงกับ plus state ในกรณีของ X observable และ outcome จะเป็นหนึ่งสำหรับ eigenvalue ลบหนึ่ง
หรือ minus state ในกรณีนี้ ทุกอย่างที่เพิ่งพูดไปขยายไปสู่ n qubit Pauli operation ได้ตามธรรมชาติ
ตราบที่เราจำไว้ว่าเมื่อเราคิดถึง observable เราพูดถึงการวัด eigenvalue
ไม่ใช่การวัดในเทอมของ basis ของ eigenvector ตัวอย่างเช่น ลองพิจารณา
Pauli operation สอง qubit Z tensor Z อีกครั้ง มี eigenvalue สองตัว บวกหนึ่งและลบหนึ่ง ดังนั้น
measurement อธิบายด้วย projection สองตัว สังเกตเป็นพิเศษว่า measurement ที่เราเชื่อมโยงกับ
observable นี้ ไม่เหมือนกับการวัดทั้งสอง qubit ด้วย Z measurement หรือพูดอีกแบบคือ standard basis measurement แต่มันเป็น
projective measurement สอง outcome ที่ projection ลงบน space ที่ span โดย eigenvector ทั้งหมดที่สอดคล้องกับ
eigenvalue แต่ละตัว บวกหนึ่งและลบหนึ่ง อีกวิธีคิดคือ eigenvalue ของ tensor
product คือผลคูณของ eigenvalue ของ matrix แต่ละตัวที่เราเอามา tensor product และ
เพราะว่าลบ 1 คูณลบ 1 เท่ากับบวก 1 คูณบวก 1 เป็นต้น measurement นี้ไม่
แยกแยะระหว่าง 0 0 กับ 1 1 ดังนั้นถ้าเราวัด สมมติ phi plus Bell state ด้วย measurement
ที่อธิบายโดย observable นี้ เราจะได้ outcome ที่สอดคล้องกับ eigenvalue บวกหนึ่งแน่นอน
และ state จะไม่เปลี่ยนแปลง แทนที่จะ collapse เป็น 0 0 หรือ 1 1 ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่จะเกิดขึ้นถ้าเรา
ทำ standard basis measurement บนสอง qubit ดังนั้น Z tensor Z measurement ไม่ใช่
สิ่งเดียวกับการทำ Z measurement สองตัวแยกกัน แต่จริงๆ แล้วเราสามารถทำ measurement แบบนี้โดยใช้ phase
estimation ในวิธีเดียวกันกับก่อนหน้า โดยใช้ control qubit เดียว ตามที่แสดงใน circuit diagram ซึ่ง
ขยายได้สำหรับ n qubit Pauli operation ใดๆ แทนที่ Z tensor Z เมื่อเรามีแค่ Z Pauli matrix
เราสามารถทำ circuit ให้ง่ายขึ้นแบบนี้ และสิ่งที่เห็นได้ ซึ่งก็ชัดเจนจาก projection ที่นิยาม
measurement ก็คือ การทำ Z tensor Z measurement บนสอง qubit เทียบเท่ากับการวัด parity ของมัน
คิดในเทอมของ standard basis และนี่ขยายได้สำหรับ tensor product ของ Z Pauli
matrix จำนวนเท่าไหร่ก็ได้ ต่อไปเราจะดู three-bit repetition code อีกครั้ง คราวนี้อธิบายในเทอมของ Pauli
operation นี่จะเป็นตัวอย่างแรกที่ค่อนข้างง่ายของ stabilizer code และเราจะพูดถึงวิธี generalize แนวคิดนี้
ในไม่ช้า แต่มันมีประโยชน์ที่จะดูว่ามันทำงานยังไงในกรณีง่ายๆ นี้ก่อน จำได้ว่าเมื่อเราใช้
3-bit repetition code กับ qubit เรา encode qubit state alpha 0 บวก beta 1 เป็น alpha 000 บวก beta 111
และเราจะเรียก encoding สาม qubit นี้ว่า psi เพื่อความสะดวก ดังนั้นตามนิยาม psi เป็น valid three qubit
encoding ของ qubit state แต่ถ้าเราต้องการตรวจสอบ ก็พอแค่ตรวจสอบว่าสมการสองข้อต่อไปนี้เป็นจริง
สมการแรกบอกว่าการใช้ Z operation กับสอง qubit ซ้ายสุดของ psi ไม่ทำอะไรกับ psi ซึ่งหมายความว่า
psi เป็น eigenvector ของ Z tensor Z tensor Identity หรือเขียนสั้นๆ ว่า ZZI ที่มี eigenvalue หนึ่ง และสมการ
ที่สองก็คล้ายกัน ยกเว้นว่า Z operation ถูกใช้กับสอง qubit ขวาสุด แนวคิดคือถ้าเราคิดถึง psi
ในฐานะ linear combination ของ standard basis state แล้ว สมการแรกบอกว่าเราจะมี coefficient ที่ไม่เป็นศูนย์ได้แค่สำหรับ standard basis state
ที่สอง bit ซ้ายสุดมี parity เป็นคู่ หรือพูดอีกแบบคือเท่ากัน และสมการที่สองบอกว่า
เราจะมี coefficient ที่ไม่เป็นศูนย์ได้แค่สำหรับ standard basis state ที่สอง bit ขวาสุดมี parity เป็นคู่ อีกวิธีคิด
คือมอง Pauli operation สองตัวนี้เป็น observable และถ้าเราวัด observable สองตัวนี้โดยใช้
circuit แบบง่ายที่ผมเพิ่งพูดถึง เราจะได้ measurement outcome ที่สอดคล้องกับ eigenvalue บวกหนึ่งแน่นอน
เพราะ psi เป็น eigenvector ของ observable ทั้งสองตัวที่มี eigenvalue หนึ่ง แต่ circuit แบบง่ายนี้ของ
circuit รวมกันสำหรับการวัด observable แยกกัน ก็ไม่ใช่อะไรอื่นนอกจาก parity check circuit ของเราสำหรับ 3-bit
repetition code ดังนั้นเราเห็นว่าสมการสองข้อของเรารวมกันเทียบเท่ากับ parity check circuit ที่ให้ผลลัพธ์ 0 0
ซึ่งเป็น syndrome ที่บ่งบอกว่าไม่พบ error Pauli operation สาม qubit
ZZI และ IZZ เรียกว่า stabilizer generator สำหรับ code นี้ และ stabilizer ของ code คือเซตที่
generate โดย stabilizer generator เซตนี้ stabilizer เป็นวัตถุทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่สำคัญอย่างยิ่ง
ที่เชื่อมโยงกับ code นี้ และเราจะพูดเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับบทบาทของมันในบทเรียนต่อไป สำหรับตอนนี้
ผมจะแค่ชี้ให้เห็นว่าเราสามารถเลือก generator ต่างออกไปได้ เช่น เราสามารถเลือก ZIZ แทนที่
generator ตัวใดตัวหนึ่งที่เราเลือก แล้ว code และ stabilizer ก็จะเหมือนเดิมทุกประการ ต่อไปเราจะพิจารณา bit flip
detection สำหรับ three-bit repetition code โดยเน้นที่ปฏิสัมพันธ์และความสัมพันธ์ระหว่าง Pauli
operation ที่เกี่ยวข้อง ได้แก่ stabilizer generator และ error เอง สมมติว่าเรา encode
qubit โดยใช้ three-bit repetition code แล้ว bit flip error เกิดขึ้นบน qubit ซ้ายสุด ทำให้ state psi ของเรา
ถูกเปลี่ยนตาม X operation หรือ X error บน qubit ซ้ายสุด อย่างที่เรารู้แล้ว เราสามารถตรวจจับ
error นี้โดยทำ parity check สำหรับ three-bit repetition code หรือเทียบเท่า เราสามารถวัด
encoding อย่าง non-destructive โดยถือว่า stabilizer generator เป็น observable เริ่มจาก
stabilizer generator ตัวแรก และดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น state ของเราถูกกระทบจาก X error และเราอยากเข้าใจ
ว่า measurement ของ stabilizer generator ในฐานะ observable ถูกกระทบอย่างไรจาก error นี้ X กับ Z anticommute กัน
ทุกอย่าง commute กับ identity matrix ดังนั้น ZZI anticommute กับ XII
ดังนั้นเราได้เครื่องหมายลบเมื่อสลับลำดับ และเรายังรู้ว่า ZZI ไม่ทำอะไรกับ psi
เพราะ psi เป็น encoding ที่ valid และ encoding ที่ valid จะเป็น eigenvector ค่าบวกหนึ่งของ stabilizer
generator ทั้งสองเสมอ เหลือแค่ลบ XII ที่ใช้กับ psi ดังนั้น XII ที่ใช้กับ
psi เป็น eigenvector ของ ZZI ที่มี eigenvalue ลบหนึ่ง เราสามารถทำคล้ายๆ กัน
กับ stabilizer generator ตัวที่สอง แต่คราวนี้ error commute กับ stabilizer generator ดังนั้น
state ที่เสียหายยังเป็น eigenvector ของ stabilizer generator แต่คราวนี้ eigenvalue เป็นบวก
หนึ่ง ดังนั้น state ที่เสียหายเป็น eigenvector ของ stabilizer generator ทั้งสอง และว่า eigenvalue เป็นบวกหนึ่งหรือ
ลบหนึ่ง ขึ้นอยู่กับว่า error commute หรือ anticommute กับ stabilizer generator แต่ละตัว สำหรับตัวแรก
error กับ stabilizer generator anticommute กัน และสำหรับตัวที่สองมันก็ commute กัน และมันจะเป็นอย่างใดอย่างหนึ่งเสมอ เพราะ Pauli
operation สองตัวจะ commute หรือ anticommute กัน ในขณะเดียวกัน state psi จริงๆ ไม่ได้มีบทบาท
สำคัญมากตรงนี้ นอกจากว่า stabilizer generator act อย่าง trivial บน state นี้ ดังนั้นเมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
การตรวจจับ error เราไม่ต้องกังวลเกี่ยวกับ state ที่ encode จริงๆ สิ่งที่สำคัญคือ error commute หรือ anticommute
กับ stabilizer generator แต่ละตัว ดังนั้นมาทำตารางที่มีหนึ่งแถวสำหรับ stabilizer generator แต่ละตัว
และหนึ่งคอลัมน์สำหรับ error แต่ละตัว ตรงนี้ผมใส่แค่ error ที่สอดคล้องกับ bit flip เดียว
รวมถึงไม่มี error เลย ซึ่งแทนด้วย identity tensor กับตัวเองสามครั้ง เราสามารถเพิ่มคอลัมน์สำหรับ error อื่นๆ ได้
แต่ตอนนี้เราจะโฟกัสแค่ error เหล่านี้ ค่าในตารางเป็นบวกหนึ่งหรือลบหนึ่ง ขึ้นอยู่กับ
ว่า error กับ stabilizer generator commute หรือ anticommute ดังนั้นสำหรับ error แต่ละตัวในตาราง เราสามารถดู
คอลัมน์ที่สอดคล้องเพื่อดูว่า error นั้นจะเปลี่ยน encoding ใดๆ เป็น eigenvector ค่าบวกหนึ่งหรือลบหนึ่ง
ของ stabilizer generator แต่ละตัวอย่างไร คอลัมน์เหล่านี้ตรงกับ syndrome ที่เราจะได้จาก
parity check ซึ่งเทียบเท่ากับ measurement อย่าง non-destructive ของ stabilizer generator ในฐานะ
observable แน่นอนว่าค่าในตารางเป็นบวกหนึ่งและลบหนึ่ง แทนที่จะเป็นศูนย์และหนึ่ง ตามลำดับ
และถ้าอยากจะ ก็คิดว่า syndrome เป็น binary string ที่สอดคล้องแทนที่จะเป็นคอลัมน์ของบวกหนึ่งและลบหนึ่งก็ได้ แต่มัน
สอดคล้องกันโดยตรง และเพื่อให้การเชื่อมโยงระหว่าง syndrome กับ eigenvalue ชัดเจนและตรงมากขึ้น
ผมจะเรียก vector ของบวกหนึ่งและลบหนึ่งเหล่านี้ว่า syndrome เหมือนเดิม syndrome บอก
เราบางอย่างเกี่ยวกับ error ที่เกิดขึ้น และโดยเฉพาะถ้าเรารู้ว่า error ที่เป็นไปได้สี่ตัวนี้
ตัวใดตัวหนึ่งเกิดขึ้น syndrome จะบอกเราว่าเป็นตัวไหน และเราสามารถแก้ไขได้โดยใช้ error นั้นอีกครั้ง ถ้าเรา
เลือก ต่อไปผมจะพูดเพิ่มอีกนิดเกี่ยวกับ syndrome โดยเฉพาะเราจะดูด้านพีชคณิตของมัน
ให้ใกล้ชิดขึ้น encoding ของเราเป็น state สาม qubit ดังนั้นเป็น unit vector ในปริภูมิ vector เชิงซ้อน
แปดมิติ และ syndrome ที่เป็นไปได้สี่ตัวทำคือแบ่งปริภูมิแปดมิตินี้
ออกเป็น subspace สองมิติสี่อัน หมายความว่า vector ใดๆ ในหนึ่งใน subspace เหล่านี้จะให้เรา syndrome เดียวกันเสมอ
ในรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติม diagram นี้แสดงว่าปริภูมิแปดมิติถูกแบ่งอย่างไร
stabilizer generator แต่ละตัวแบ่งปริภูมิออกเป็นสอง subspace ที่มีมิติเท่ากัน ได้แก่ space ของ eigenvector ค่าบวกหนึ่ง
และ space ของ eigenvector ค่าลบหนึ่ง ตัวอย่างเช่น eigenvector ค่าบวกหนึ่งของ ZZI คือ linear combination
ของ standard basis state ที่สอง bit ซ้ายสุดมี parity เป็นคู่ และ eigenvector ค่าลบหนึ่งคือ linear
combination ของ standard basis state ที่สอง bit ซ้ายสุดมี parity เป็นคี่ และสถานการณ์ก็คล้ายกันสำหรับ
stabilizer generator ตัวอื่น ยกเว้นว่าเป็นสอง bit ขวาสุดแทนที่จะเป็นซ้ายสุด ดังนั้น subspace ทั้งสี่อธิบายได้
ง่ายในกรณีนี้ เนื่องจากเป็น code ที่ง่ายมาก โดยเฉพาะ subspace
ที่สอดคล้องกับ syndrome บวกหนึ่ง บวกหนึ่ง คือ space ที่ span โดย ket 000 และ ket 111 ซึ่งเป็น space ของ
encoding ที่ valid และเรียกว่า code space และโดยทั่วไป space ต่างๆ ถูก span โดย standard basis state
ที่แสดงในช่องสี่เหลี่ยมที่สอดคล้อง แม้ว่ามันจะไม่ชัดหรือเห็นง่ายเท่าไหร่ syndrome
ยังแบ่ง Pauli operation สาม qubit ทั้งหมด ซึ่งแทน Pauli error ที่อาจเกิดขึ้นได้ ออกเป็นกลุ่มขนาดเท่ากันสี่กลุ่ม
ขึ้นอยู่กับว่า error นั้นจะทำให้เกิด syndrome ใด ตัวอย่างเช่น Pauli operation
ที่ commute กับ stabilizer generator ทั้งสองให้ syndrome บวกหนึ่ง บวกหนึ่ง และในบรรดา Pauli
operation สาม qubit 64 ตัวที่เป็นไปได้ มี 16 ตัวพอดีที่อยู่ในหมวดนี้ รวมถึงสามตัวที่แสดงบนจอ และเช่นเดียวกันสำหรับอีกสาม
syndrome มันไม่ชัดเจน แต่เป็นเรื่องจริง และคุณสมบัติพื้นฐานนี้ที่ syndrome แบ่งทั้ง state space
ที่ encoding อยู่ และ Pauli error ที่เป็นไปได้ทั้งหมดในปริภูมิออกเป็นชิ้นขนาดเท่ากัน เป็นสิ่งที่
เป็นจริงโดยทั่วไปสำหรับ stabilizer code ซึ่งเราจะนิยามอย่างแม่นยำในไม่ช้า แม้ว่าส่วนใหญ่เป็นแค่เรื่องข้างเคียง
ณ จุดนี้ มันน่าพูดถึงว่า Pauli operation ที่ commute กับ stabilizer generator ทั้งสอง หรือเทียบเท่าว่า
Pauli operation ที่ให้ syndrome บวกหนึ่ง บวกหนึ่ง แต่ตัวมันเองไม่ได้เป็นสัดส่วนของ element ของ stabilizer กลับประพฤติตัวเหมือน
Pauli operation qubit เดียวบน logical qubit ที่เรา encode ตัวอย่างเช่น XXX commute กับ
stabilizer generator ทั้งสอง แต่ไม่ได้เป็นสัดส่วนของ element ใดใน stabilizer และจริงๆ มันชัดเจนถ้าคิด
เกี่ยวกับ code นี้สักครู่ว่า ผลกระทบที่ operation นี้มีต่อ encoding เทียบเท่ากับ X gate บน
logical qubit ที่ถูก encode และอีกครั้งนี่เป็นสิ่งที่ขยายได้กับ stabilizer code ทุกตัว ตอนนี้ถึงเวลานิยาม stabilizer
code โดยทั่วไปแล้ว วิธีการทำงานก็คือ เราทำอะไรที่คล้ายกันกับที่เราเพิ่งพูดถึงสำหรับ
three-bit repetition code ยกเว้นว่าเราเลือก stabilizer generator ต่างออกไป ซึ่งทั้งหมดจะเรียกว่า P1
ถึง PR สำหรับคำอธิบายนี้ stabilizer generator เหล่านี้ต้องเป็น n qubit Pauli operation ทั้งหมด
โดย n คือจำนวน qubit ที่ใช้สำหรับ encoding และเราเลือก stabilizer generator มั่วๆ ไม่ได้ พวกมัน
ต้องเป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขพื้นฐานหลายข้อ อันดับแรก stabilizer generator ต้อง commute กัน
ทั้งหมด ในกรณีของ three-bit repetition code เราไม่ได้สังเกตเรื่องนี้ แต่สังเกตได้ง่ายว่า ZZI และ
IZZ commute กันจริง เพราะ Z commute กับตัวเอง และทุกอย่าง commute กับ
identity สำหรับ stabilizer code ที่มี stabilizer generator ซับซ้อนกว่า รวมถึง code ที่มี
ทั้ง X และ Z ปรากฏใน stabilizer generator เงื่อนไขนี้สำคัญที่ต้อง
ตรวจสอบ วิธีหนึ่งที่คิดเกี่ยวกับความจำเป็นของเงื่อนไขนี้คือ เราจะถือว่า stabilizer generator เป็น observable และโดยการกำหนดให้
พวกมัน commute กันทั้งหมด เรารับประกันว่าลำดับที่เราทำ measurement เหล่านี้ไม่
สำคัญ อันดับที่สอง stabilizer generator ต้องเป็น minimal generating set หมายความว่าถ้าเราเอาตัวใดตัวหนึ่ง
ออก เราจะได้ stabilizer ที่เล็กกว่า และวิธีหนึ่งที่จะแสดงนี้ทางคณิตศาสตร์แสดงอยู่บน
จอ พูดตรงๆ เงื่อนไขนี้ไม่ได้จำเป็นจริงๆ สำหรับวิธีที่ stabilizer code ทำงานในเชิงปฏิบัติ
และบางครั้งมันก็สมเหตุสมผลที่จะคิดถึง non-minimal generating set อย่างที่เราจะเห็นในบทเรียนถัดไป แต่
เพื่อการวิเคราะห์ stabilizer code และอธิบายคุณสมบัติของมัน เราจะสมมติว่าเงื่อนไขนี้เป็น
จริง โดยพื้นฐาน เงื่อนไขนี้รับประกันว่า observable แต่ละตัวที่เราวัดเพื่อได้ syndrome กำลังเพิ่ม
ข้อมูลเกี่ยวกับ error ที่เป็นไปได้ แทนที่จะซ้ำซ้อนและให้ผลลัพธ์ที่สามารถอนุมานได้ง่ายจาก stabilizer generator ตัวอื่นในฐานะ
observable และสุดท้าย ต้องมีอย่างน้อยหนึ่ง vector ที่ไม่เป็นศูนย์ที่ถูก fix โดย
stabilizer generator ทั้งหมด และนั่นเทียบเท่ากับการกำหนดว่า -1 คูณ identity บน n qubit ไม่
อยู่ใน stabilizer มันไม่ชัดเจน แต่ประเด็นคือ มันเป็นไปได้ที่จะเลือก minimal generating
set ของ n qubit Pauli operation ที่ commute กันทั้งหมด แต่ไม่มี vector ใดที่เป็น eigenvector ค่าบวกหนึ่ง
ของทั้งหมดพร้อมกัน และเราไม่อยากกังวลกับกรณีนี้ เพราะ code ที่ไม่มี encoding ที่ valid ไม่
น่าสนใจ นั่นคือเงื่อนไขสำหรับ stabilizer generator ของ stabilizer code และถ้าเรามี generator ชุดหนึ่งที่
เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขเหล่านี้ ก็ได้ stabilizer code ที่ valid และเราสามารถพิจารณาคุณสมบัติของมัน มี
stabilizer code ที่แตกต่างกันมากมายที่มีคุณสมบัติต่างๆ ที่ทำให้น่าสนใจหรือไม่ แต่ทั้งหมดเป็นไปตามคุณสมบัติพื้นฐาน
บางอย่างที่คล้ายกับที่เราสังเกตเห็นแล้วสำหรับ three-bit repetition code
เราจะดูตัวอย่างบางอันในไม่ช้า แต่ก่อนหน้านั้น ขอบอกว่าเมื่อเราพูดถึง code space ของ stabilizer code เราหมายถึง subspace
ของ state space n qubit ที่รวมทุก vector ที่เป็น eigenvector ค่าบวกหนึ่งของ stabilizer generator ทุกตัว
พร้อมกัน นี่คือ subspace ของ state space n qubit ที่ encoding ที่ valid อยู่ และเราจะพูดเพิ่มเติม
เกี่ยวกับ subspace นี้ในบทเรียนต่อไป ตอนนี้มาดูตัวอย่างบางอันของ stabilizer
code นี่คือตัวอย่างที่เราพูดถึงแล้ว 3-bit repetition code ธรรมดา และเรายังสามารถแสดง
version ที่ปรับแต่งของ code นั้นจากบทเรียนก่อนหน้า ซึ่งสามารถตรวจจับ phase flip แทน bit flip เป็น stabilizer code ตามที่แสดง
ตรงนี้ คราวนี้ stabilizer generator วัด XX observable แทน ZZ observable ดังนั้นพวกนี้โดยหลักแล้วเป็น
parity check ใน plus minus basis แทน standard basis ในทั้งสองกรณี เราสามารถ
เห็นได้ทันทีว่าเรามี stabilizer code ที่ valid เพราะ stabilizer generator commute กัน เป็น minimal
generating set และ code space ไม่ trivial อย่างที่เรารู้แล้ว แต่เราก็เห็นได้ค่อนข้างชัดว่าเรา
ไม่สามารถ generate ลบหนึ่งคูณ identity ได้ และนี่คือ 9 qubit Shore code ซึ่งก็เป็น stabilizer code
ที่แสดงด้วย stabilizer generator ในกรณีนี้เรามีโดยหลักแล้วสามสำเนาของ three-bit
repetition code หนึ่งสำเนาสำหรับแต่ละบล็อกของสาม qubit รวมถึง stabilizer generator สองตัวสุดท้ายที่
มีรูปแบบคล้าย circuit ที่เราเห็นในบทเรียนก่อนสำหรับการตรวจจับ phase flip สำหรับ
code นี้ อีกวิธีคิดเกี่ยวกับ stabilizer generator สองตัวสุดท้ายคือ พวกมันมีรูปแบบเหมือนกับ
ที่เรามีสำหรับ three-bit repetition code สำหรับ phase flip ยกเว้นว่าเราแทน X ด้วย XXX และเหตุผลคือ
XXX สอดคล้องกับ X operation บน logical qubit ที่ encode โดย 3-bit repetition code แต่
นั่นเป็นเรื่องข้างเคียง และไม่ต้องกังวลตอนนี้ ในกรณีที่ยังไม่ชัด ต่อไปเราจะดูตัวอย่าง
เพิ่มอีกสักหน่อย แต่ก่อนหน้านั้น ขอบอกว่าคนมักจะละสัญลักษณ์ tensor product เมื่ออธิบาย stabilizer code เพราะมักจะ
ทำให้อ่านง่ายขึ้น นี่คือ code เหล่านี้เมื่อไม่มีสัญลักษณ์ tensor product
แต่แน่นอนว่าพวกนี้เป็น tensor product ไม่ใช่การคูณ matrix ธรรมดา เช่น เราแค่ละสัญลักษณ์ tensor product เพื่อให้มันไม่รก
เกินไป และ pattern ชัดเจนกว่า นี่คืออีกตัวอย่างหนึ่ง เรียกว่า
7 qubit Steane code และมันมีคุณสมบัติที่น่าทึ่งมาก เราจะกลับมาที่ตัวนี้
เป็นระยะๆ ตลอดบทเรียนที่เหลือของหน่วยนี้ แต่ตอนนี้เราสามารถตรวจสอบได้เลยว่ามันเป็น stabilizer
code ที่ valid โดยเฉพาะ stabilizer generator สามตัวแรก commute กันอย่างชัดเจน เพราะ Z commute กับ
ตัวเอง และ identity commute กับทุกอย่าง และสถานการณ์ก็คล้ายกันสำหรับสามตัวสุดท้าย ดังนั้นก็เหลือต้อง
ตรวจว่า ถ้าเราเอา Z stabilizer generator ตัวหนึ่งกับ X stabilizer generator ตัวหนึ่ง พวกมัน commute กัน
และง่ายพอที่จะตรวจทั้งเก้าคู่ ในทุกกรณีเราจะ
มี X กับ Z จับคู่กันในตำแหน่งเดียวกันจำนวนคู่ครั้ง ดังนั้น generator สองตัวจะ commute กัน เหมือนกับ
XX กับ ZZ ที่ commute กัน เป็น minimal generating set และมี code space ที่ไม่ trivial แต่
ผมจะไม่พยายามอ้างเรื่องนั้นในวิดีโอนี้ และจะปล่อยให้คิดเอง 7 qubit Steane code คล้ายกับ
9 qubit Shore code ตรงที่มัน encode qubit เดียว และแก้ไข error ใดๆ บน qubit หนึ่งตัวได้ แต่ใช้แค่
เจ็ด qubit แทนเก้า นั่นไม่ใช่จำนวน qubit น้อยที่สุดที่ต้องใช้สำหรับ error correcting code ที่จะ
encode qubit แล้วแก้ไข error ใดๆ บน qubit เดียวได้ นี่คือ stabilizer code ที่มักเรียกว่า
five qubit code ที่ encode qubit เดียวเช่นกัน และแก้ไข error บน qubit เดียวได้
และห้าคือจำนวน qubit น้อยที่สุดที่เป็นไปได้สำหรับเรื่องนี้ นี่คืออีกตัวอย่างของ
stabilizer code แม้ว่ามันจะไม่ใช่ code จริงๆ พูดง่ายๆ คือ code space เป็น
หนึ่งมิติ โดยเฉพาะ code space ของ code นี้คือ space ที่ span โดย ebit หรือพูดอีกแบบคือ phi plus
Bell state ดังนั้นจริงๆ แล้ว encode qubit ไม่ได้ด้วย code นี้ แต่มันก็ยังเป็น stabilizer code ที่ valid โดย code
space บังเอิญเป็นหนึ่งมิติ และสามารถทำอะไรคล้ายๆ กันสำหรับ GHZ
state นั่นคือตัวอย่างบางอันของ stabilizer code และเราจะเห็นตัวอย่างอีกเยอะมากใน
บทเรียนถัดไป สมมติว่าเรามี stabilizer code คำถามธรรมชาติที่จะถามเกี่ยวกับมัน
อาจเป็นคำถามแรกที่นึกถึง คือมัน encode กี่ qubit คำถามนี้มีคำตอบง่ายมาก
และเพื่ออธิบาย มาระบุให้ชัดเกี่ยวกับ stabilizer code ที่พิจารณา เรามี R n qubit
stabilizer generator P1 ถึง PR ที่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสามข้อที่ผมพูดถึงก่อนหน้า คือ
stabilizer generator commute กันทั้งหมด เป็น minimal generating set ดังนั้นจะไม่ได้ stabilizer
เดิมถ้าเอา generator ตัวหนึ่งออก และมีอย่างน้อยหนึ่ง vector ที่ไม่เป็นศูนย์ใน code
space ตามทฤษฎีบทบนจอ จะต้องเป็นว่า code space ของ stabilizer code มี
มิติ 2 ยกกำลัง n ลบ R หรือพูดอีกแบบคือเราสามารถ encode n
ลบ R qubit ด้วย code นี้ ดังนั้นโดยสัญชาตญาณ เรามี n qubit ใน encoding และ
stabilizer generator แต่ละตัวเอา qubit ออกไปหนึ่งตัว ในแง่ของจำนวน qubit ที่เรา encode ได้
ทฤษฎีบทนี้พิสูจน์ไม่ยาก และผมจะแสดงบทพิสูจน์ในอีกสักครู่ แต่ก่อนอื่นเรามาดูตัวอย่าง
สักสองสามอัน เริ่มจาก 3-bit repetition code ธรรมดา เรามีสาม qubit ใน
encoding ดังนั้น n เท่ากับสาม และมี R เท่ากับสอง stabilizer generator ดังนั้นเรา encode ได้หนึ่ง
qubit ด้วย code นี้ สังเกตว่านี่ไม่เกี่ยวกับว่า error ตัวไหนหรือกี่ตัวที่ตรวจจับหรือ
แก้ไขได้ นั่นเป็นเรื่องอื่น นี่แค่เป็นเรื่องเกี่ยวกับมิติของ code
space สำหรับอีกตัวอย่าง ลองพิจารณา 5 qubit code ที่มีห้า qubit และสี่
stabilizer generator ดังนั้น code space มีมิติสองอีกครั้ง หมายความว่าเรา encode ได้หนึ่ง qubit ด้วย
code นี้ และอีกตัวอย่างตอนนี้ สำหรับ ebit stabilizer code เรามีสอง qubit และสอง stabilizer generator ดังนั้น
code space เป็นหนึ่งมิติ และอย่างที่พูดไปก่อนหน้า มันคือ space ที่ span โดย phi plus Bell state
เราจะเห็นตัวอย่างเพิ่มเติม รวมถึง code ที่ encode ได้มากกว่าหนึ่ง qubit แต่ตอนนี้มาดู
ว่าเราจะพิสูจน์ทฤษฎีบทนี้ได้ยังไง สิ่งแรกที่ต้องสังเกตคือ เพราะ stabilizer
generator commute กัน และเป็น minimal generating set และเพราะ Pauli operation ทุกตัวเป็น inverse ของตัวเอง ทุก
element ใน stabilizer สามารถแสดงได้อย่างเป็นเอกลักษณ์เป็นผลคูณที่เรายกกำลัง stabilizer generator
PK ด้วย AK โดยแต่ละ AK เป็นศูนย์หรือหนึ่ง แล้วคูณผลลัพธ์เข้า
ด้วยกัน อีกวิธีพูดคือ เราได้ทุก element ของ stabilizer โดยคูณ subset บางอันของ
stabilizer generator เข้าด้วยกัน และเราไม่มีทางได้ stabilizer element เดิมจาก subset ต่างกัน และสิ่งหนึ่งที่
บอกเป็นนัยคือ วิธีเดียวที่จะแสดง identity operation n qubit ในวิธีนี้คือเอากำลังทั้งหมดเป็น
ศูนย์ ต่อไปให้นิยาม pi K เป็น projection ลงบน eigenspace ค่าบวกหนึ่งของ PK สำหรับแต่ละ K จาก 1 ถึง R และมี
สูตรง่ายๆ สำหรับ projection นี้ เราแค่เฉลี่ย PK กับ identity บน n qubit ซึ่งปล่อย
eigenvalue บวกหนึ่งไว้เหมือนเดิม และเลื่อน eigenvalue ลบหนึ่งทั้งหมดเป็นศูนย์
ทีนี้ code space ถูกนิยามเป็นเซตของ vector ทั้งหมดที่เป็น eigenvector ค่าบวกหนึ่งของ stabilizer
generator ทั้งหมดพร้อมกัน เมื่อ stabilizer generator commute กัน projection ก็ต้อง commute กันด้วย และนั่น
บอกว่าผลคูณของ projection เหล่านี้ก็เป็น projection ด้วย และโดยเฉพาะมันเป็น projection ลงบน
intersection ของ subspace ที่ projection แต่ละตัว project ลงไป หรือพูดอีกแบบคือมันเป็น projection ลงบน
code space เราสามารถกระจายผลคูณนี้ออก แล้วจะได้ค่าเฉลี่ยบนทุก
element ของ stabilizer และสุดท้าย เพราะมิติของ subspace ใดๆ เท่ากับ
trace ของ projection ลงบน subspace นั้น เราพบว่ามิติของ code space คือค่าเฉลี่ยของ trace บน element ของ
stabilizer แต่ยกเว้น identity operation n qubit ทุก element ของ stabilizer จะมี
trace เท่ากับศูนย์ เพราะ non-identity Pauli matrix ทั้งสามตัวมี trace เป็นศูนย์ trace ของ identity
operation n qubit คือ 2 ยกกำลัง n ดังนั้นเราพบว่ามิติของ code space คือ 2 ยกกำลัง n ลบ R ซึ่งพิสูจน์
ทฤษฎีบท ต่อไปผมจะพูดนิดหน่อยเกี่ยวกับวิธี encode qubit โดยใช้ stabilizer code แต่ต้อง
แนะนำ Clifford operation ก่อน Clifford operation คือ unitary operation บน qubit จำนวนเท่าไหร่ก็ได้
ที่สามารถทำได้ด้วย quantum circuit ที่มี gate ชุดจำกัด ได้แก่ Hadamard gate, S gate
และ controlled-NOT gate สังเกตว่า T gate ไม่รวม รวมถึง Toffoli gate หรือ Fredkin
gate ก็ไม่รวม และ gate เหล่านั้นไม่ได้แค่ไม่อยู่ในรายการ แต่จริงๆ แล้วไม่สามารถทำ gate เหล่านั้นได้
โดยใช้ gate ที่อยู่ในรายการ ดังนั้นมันไม่ใช่ Clifford operation Pauli operation อีกด้าน
เป็น Clifford operation และโดยเฉพาะมันสามารถทำได้โดยใช้ลำดับของ Hadamard และ S
gate นั่นเป็นวิธีง่ายๆ ในการนิยาม Clifford operation แต่มันไม่ได้อธิบายจริงๆ ว่าทำไมถึงนิยามแบบ
นี้ หรืออะไรพิเศษเกี่ยวกับ gate ชุดนี้ นี่คือเหตุผลจริงๆ ที่ Clifford operation ถูกนิยามแบบ
นี้ ถ้าไม่สนใจ global phase แล้ว Clifford operation n qubit คือ unitary
operation ที่แปลง Pauli operation เป็น Pauli operation เสมอผ่าน conjugation พูดให้แม่นยำขึ้น unitary
operation n qubit U เป็น Clifford operation ถ้าไม่สนใจ global phase ก็ต่อเมื่อ สำหรับทุก n qubit Pauli
operation การ conjugate Pauli operation นั้นด้วย U ให้เราบวกหรือลบหนึ่งคูณ n
qubit Pauli operation อีกตัว (อาจต่างออกไป) ตรวจสอบได้ง่ายว่าคุณสมบัตินี้เป็นจริงสำหรับ Hadamard gate, S
gate และ CNOT gate ดังนั้นมันจำเป็นต้องเป็นจริงสำหรับ circuit ที่สร้างจาก gate เหล่านี้ สิ่งที่พิสูจน์ยากกว่าคือว่ามัน
ไปในทิศทางตรงข้าม คือถ้าเรามี unitary operation n qubit U ที่เป็นไปตามคุณสมบัตินี้
มันต้องสามารถทำได้ ถ้าไม่สนใจ global phase โดยใช้แค่ Hadamard, S และ CNOT
gate ผมจะไม่พิสูจน์นัยนี้ แต่มันเป็นจริง และสามารถหาอ่านเพิ่มได้ถ้า
สนใจ Clifford operation ไม่ใช่ universal สำหรับ quantum computation หมายความว่าเราทำ quantum
computation ใดๆ ไม่ได้ด้วยแค่ Hadamard, S และ CNOT gate จริงๆ สำหรับค่า n ที่กำหนด มีแค่จำนวนจำกัด
ของ Clifford operation n qubit ดังนั้นเป็น discrete set ของ operation ไม่เหมือนกับ
universal set ของ quantum gate เราไม่สามารถ approximate unitary operation ใดๆ ได้ตามความแม่นยำที่ต้องการ และ
จริงๆ แล้ว การทำ Clifford operation บน standard basis state ตามด้วย standard basis measurement ไม่สามารถ
ทำ computation ที่เกินขอบเขตของ classical algorithm ได้ เพราะเราสามารถ simulate computation แบบนี้ได้
อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพบนคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก ข้อเท็จจริงนี้เรียกว่า Gottesman-Knill theorem และบทพิสูจน์มาตรฐานของทฤษฎีบทนี้ในบางแง่
อิงกับ stabilizer formalism โดยเฉพาะ วิธีที่มันทำงานคือ เราสามารถติดตามว่า Clifford operation แปลง Pauli
operation ผ่าน conjugation อย่างไร ซึ่งสามารถทำได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ แล้วอนุมานจากนั้นว่า computation ทำอะไรกับ
qubit แล้วมันเกี่ยวอะไรกับ stabilizer code ล่ะ stabilizer code ให้เรา
code space ที่มีมิติหนึ่ง และเรามีอิสระที่จะใช้ code space นั้นยังไงก็ได้ ดังนั้นไม่มีอะไรบังคับให้เรา encode
qubit เข้าไปใน space นั้นด้วยวิธีเฉพาะ แต่มันจะทำได้เสมอที่จะ encode โดยใช้ Clifford operation
เป็น encoder นั่นดีเพราะ Clifford operation ค่อนข้างเรียบง่ายเมื่อเทียบกับ unitary
operation ทั่วไป มีวิธี optimize การทำงานของมัน ซึ่งทำงานคล้ายกับบทพิสูจน์ของ Gottesman-
Knill theorem และจากนั้น circuit สำหรับทำมันไม่จำเป็นต้องใหญ่เกินไป
โดยเฉพาะ เราสามารถ encode ได้เสมอโดยใช้ Clifford operation ที่ต้องการ gate จำนวนน้อยกว่ากำลังสองเล็กน้อย
เพราะจริงๆ แล้วมันเป็นจริงสำหรับ Clifford operation ทุกตัว ดังนั้นผลลัพธ์คือ สำหรับ stabilizer code ที่กำหนด
สามารถ encode qubit ได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพเสมอโดยใช้ code นั้น และเครื่องมือทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่มีประโยชน์สำหรับเข้าใจ Clifford operation ช่วยได้
ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือ encoder สำหรับ 7 qubit Steane code เป็น Clifford operation และปรากฏว่า
อันนี้ไม่ต้องใช้ S gate ด้วยซ้ำ สำหรับ stabilizer code ทั่วไป การตรวจจับ error ทำงานดังนี้
เหมือนเดิม เราสมมติว่ามี n qubit stabilizer generator P1 ถึง PR และให้ E เป็น n qubit Pauli
operation ที่แทน error สมมติบน encoding เราพิจารณาแค่ Pauli
operation เป็น error เพราะ discretization of errors ทำงานเหมือนกันสำหรับ stabilizer code ใดๆ เหมือนกับ 9 qubit Shore
code วิธีที่เราตรวจ error คือวัด stabilizer generator แต่ละตัวในฐานะ
observable มี R stabilizer generator ดังนั้น outcome จะมี R ค่า โดยแต่ละค่าเป็นบวกหนึ่งหรือลบ
หนึ่ง หรือค่า binary ถ้าอยากเชื่อมโยงศูนย์กับบวกหนึ่งและหนึ่งกับลบหนึ่ง และ R outcome เหล่านี้
รวมกันเป็น syndrome เหมือนที่เรามีสำหรับ three-bit repetition code ตอนที่ R เท่ากับ
สอง โดยทั่วไปมีสามกรณีสำหรับ error E ในแง่ของการตรวจจับ ดังนี้ อันดับแรก
อาจเป็นว่า E อยู่ใน stabilizer หมายความว่าสามารถ generate E จาก stabilizer generator ได้ หรือ
กว้างกว่าเล็กน้อย E อาจเทียบเท่ากับ stabilizer element ถ้าไม่สนใจ global
phase ในกรณีนี้ E ไม่ใช่ error จริงๆ เพราะมันไม่มีผลใน code space นอกจากอาจ
ใส่ global phase ซึ่งไม่มีผลอะไร ดังนั้นเราไม่ต้องกังวลเรื่อง error แบบนี้เลย อะไรก็ตามที่
มันทำจริงๆ นอก code space ดังนั้นไม่ต้องกังวล
น่ากังวลกว่ามากคือความเป็นไปได้ที่ E ไม่ได้อยู่ใน stabilizer แม้แต่ถ้าไม่สนใจ global phase แต่
มัน commute กับ stabilizer generator ทุกตัว จำได้ว่ามันเป็น
anti-commutation ของ error กับ stabilizer generator ที่ทำให้ลบหนึ่งปรากฏใน syndrome
แต่นั่นไม่เกิดขึ้นในกรณีนี้ ดังนั้นนี่คือ error ที่เปลี่ยน vector ใน code space จริงๆ ในทาง
ที่ไม่ trivial และเรารู้เรื่องนี้เพราะไม่งั้นมันจะเป็นสัดส่วนของ stabilizer element แต่มัน
ไม่ถูกตรวจจับโดย code ดังนั้นนี่คือกรณีแย่ เรามี error ที่อาจเปลี่ยน
quantum information ที่เรา encode ไว้ แต่ code ไม่รู้เรื่องนี้เลย ตัวอย่างเช่น สำหรับ three-bit
repetition code XXX อยู่ในหมวดนี้ และความเป็นไปได้สุดท้ายคือ E
anticommute กับ stabilizer generator อย่างน้อยหนึ่งตัว และนี่หมายความว่า code ตรวจจับ error นี้ได้ เพราะ
เราจะได้ syndrome ที่มีลบหนึ่งอย่างน้อยหนึ่งที่ ซึ่งบ่งบอกว่ามีอะไรผิดปกติ แล้วเราต้องพยายามแก้ไข error นี้
นั่นคือความเป็นไปได้ทั้งหมด ในแง่ของศัพท์
เมื่อเราพูดถึง distance ของ stabilizer code เราหมายถึงน้ำหนักน้อยสุดของ Pauli operation ที่อยู่ใน
หมวดที่สอง หมายความว่ามันเปลี่ยน code space ในทางที่ไม่ trivial แต่ code ไม่
ตรวจจับเรื่องนี้ และเมื่อเราพูดว่า stabilizer code เป็น n,m,d stabilizer code โดยใช้
วงเล็บสี่เหลี่ยมคู่ตามที่แสดงบนจอ หมายความว่า encoding มีความยาว n qubit
code สามารถ encode M qubit ได้ ดังนั้น code space มีมิติ 2 ยกกำลัง M และ distance เป็น D ดังนั้น error ต้อง
มีน้ำหนัก D หรือมากกว่าจึงจะเปลี่ยน logical state ของ qubit ที่เรา encode ไว้โดยไม่ถูกตรวจจับเป็น
error ตอนนี้เรามาดู 7 qubit Steane code เป็นตัวอย่าง และเราจะหาว่า distance ของมัน
เป็นเท่าไหร่ นี่คือ stabilizer generator ของ code นี้ จำได้ว่า distance คือน้ำหนักน้อยสุดของ
n qubit Pauli operation ที่ commute กับ stabilizer generator ทั้งหมด แต่ตัวมันเองไม่อยู่ใน stabilizer หรือ
เป็นสัดส่วนของ element ของ stabilizer สิ่งที่เราจะหาคือ code นี้มี distance
สาม วิธีที่เราจะหาคือ พิจารณา Pauli operation ที่มีน้ำหนักไม่เกินสองก่อน แล้วเราจะ
สรุปว่าวิธีเดียวที่มันจะ commute กับ stabilizer generator ทั้งหกตัวคือมันเป็น identity ซึ่งเป็น element ของ
stabilizer เสมอ สมมติว่า Pauli matrix ที่อาจไม่ใช่ identity ที่ประกอบเป็น operation นี้ ซึ่งเราจะ
เรียกว่า P และ Q อยู่ที่สองตำแหน่งซ้ายสุด นี่แค่กรณีเดียว แล้วเราก็ต้อง
พิจารณาตำแหน่งอื่นๆ ที่เป็นไปได้สำหรับ Pauli matrix ที่อาจไม่ใช่ identity เหล่านี้ด้วย แต่ argument ก็เหมือนกันสำหรับทุก
ตำแหน่งที่เป็นไปได้ ตามสมมติฐาน operation นี้ commute กับ stabilizer
generator ทั้งหก ดังนั้นโดยเฉพาะมัน commute กับตัวนี้ และมัน commute กับตัว
นี้ด้วย Q จับคู่กับ identity matrix ใน generator ทั้งสอง ซึ่งเป็นเหตุผลที่เราเลือกสองตัวนี้ และเรามี identity
matrix ในห้าตำแหน่งขวาสุดของ error นี้ ดังนั้นเราสรุปว่า P ต้อง commute กับทั้ง X
และ Z เพราะไม่งั้น error นี้จะ anticommute กับ generator ตัวใดตัวหนึ่ง แต่ Pauli matrix ตัวเดียวที่
commute กับทั้ง X และ Z คือ identity ดังนั้น P ต้องเป็น identity และเมื่อรู้แล้ว เรา
สามารถเลือก stabilizer generator อีกสองตัวที่มี X และ Z ในตำแหน่งที่สองจากซ้าย แล้วเรา
สรุปได้คล้ายๆ กันเกี่ยวกับ Q ดังนั้นไม่มีทางที่ error น้ำหนักไม่เกินสองจะผ่านการตรวจจับของ code นี้ได้
นอกจากว่ามันเป็นแค่ identity operation ซึ่งอยู่ใน stabilizer ดังนั้นมันไม่ใช่
error จริงๆ ในทางกลับกัน มี Pauli operation น้ำหนักสามที่ commute กับ stabilizer generator ทั้งหก
แต่ไม่ได้เป็นสัดส่วนของ stabilizer element และนี่คือสองตัวอย่าง ดังนั้นเราสรุปว่า
code นี้มี distance สาม สิ่งสุดท้ายที่เราจะพูดถึงในบทเรียนนี้คือการแก้ไข error สำหรับ
stabilizer code เหมือนเดิม เราสมมติว่า code ระบุด้วย n qubit stabilizer generator
P1 ถึง PR แล้วเริ่มจากคิดเกี่ยวกับ error ทั้งหมดที่อาจ
เกิดขึ้น มี 2 ยกกำลัง R syndrome ที่เป็นไปได้ และอย่างที่ผมพูดไปก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน syndrome เหล่านี้แบ่ง
Pauli operation n qubit ที่เป็นไปได้ทั้งหมดออกเป็นกลุ่มขนาดเท่ากัน หมายความว่า 4 ยกกำลัง n หารด้วย 2 ยกกำลัง R Pauli operation
ในแต่ละเซต ดังนั้นเมื่อเราเห็น syndrome หนึ่ง อาจเป็นว่า error ใดก็ได้ในจำนวน 4 ยกกำลัง n หารด้วย 2
ยกกำลัง R ที่เป็นต้นเหตุ แต่เรานับเกินไปหน่อย เพราะ error บางตัว
มีผลเหมือนกันทุกประการใน code space โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเรามี error E แล้วคูณ E ด้วย
stabilizer element S ก็จะได้ error อีกตัวที่มีผลเหมือนกันใน code space กับ E ดังนั้น
พวกนี้เป็น error ที่เทียบเท่ากัน stabilizer มี 2 ยกกำลัง R element และถ้าคำนึงถึงเรื่องนี้ เราพบว่า
สำหรับแต่ละ syndrome มี 4 ยกกำลัง n ลบ R equivalence class ของ error ที่ไม่เทียบเท่ากัน ที่อาจทำให้เกิด syndrome
นั้น และนั่นหมายความว่า นอกจาก R เท่ากับ n ซึ่งเราจะมี code space หนึ่งมิติ และ
encode qubit ไม่ได้เลย มันจะไม่สามารถแก้ไข error ทุกตัวที่ตรวจจับได้ แทนที่จะทำอย่างนั้น
สิ่งที่ต้องทำคือเลือก correction operation แค่หนึ่งตัวสำหรับแต่ละ syndrome โดยหวังจะแก้ไข equivalence class ของ error แค่หนึ่ง class
แล้วเราควรเลือก correction ยังไง กลยุทธ์ธรรมชาติคือเลือก
Pauli operation น้ำหนักน้อยสุดที่ทำให้เกิด syndrome ที่เราวัดได้ โดยคิดว่า Pauli
operation น้ำหนักน้อยกว่าแทนคำอธิบายที่เป็นไปได้มากกว่าสำหรับ syndrome นั้น อาจไม่ใช่จริงเสมอไป
สำหรับ noise model บางแบบ และกลยุทธ์ธรรมชาติอีกอันคือคำนวณ error ที่น่าจะเป็นไปได้มากที่สุดที่ทำให้เกิด
syndrome นั้น แต่ตอนนี้เราจะพิจารณาแค่กลยุทธ์ที่เราพยายามแก้ไข error โดยเลือก Pauli operation น้ำหนักน้อยสุดที่ทำให้เกิด
syndrome สำหรับ stabilizer code ที่มี distance D กลยุทธ์นี้จะแก้ไข error ที่มีน้ำหนักน้อยกว่า
ครึ่งหนึ่งของ D เสมอ หรือพูดอีกแบบคือน้ำหนักไม่เกิน D ลบ 1 หารด้วย 2 และผมจะอธิบายสั้นๆ ว่าทำไม
ซึ่งจะแสดงเช่นว่า 7 qubit Steane code แก้ไข Pauli error น้ำหนักหนึ่งใดๆ ได้ และโดย
discretization of errors หมายความว่าเหมือนกับ 9 qubit Shore code Steane code สามารถแก้ไข error
ใดๆ บน qubit หนึ่งตัวได้ นี่คือวิธีที่มันทำงาน คิดว่าวงกลมนี้แทน Pauli
operation ทั้งหมดที่ให้ syndrome บวกหนึ่งทั้งหมด ซึ่งเป็น syndrome ที่บ่งบอกว่าไม่มี error เกิดขึ้น
และไม่มีอะไรผิดปกติ ในบรรดา operation เหล่านี้ เรามี element ของ stabilizer หรือจริงๆ
operation ที่เป็นสัดส่วนของ stabilizer element และเรายังมี error ที่ไม่ trivial ที่เปลี่ยน code space แต่ไม่ถูก
ตรวจจับโดย code และเรารู้จากนิยามของ distance ว่าทุก Pauli operation ในหมวดนี้ต้องมีน้ำหนักอย่างน้อย
D เพราะ D ถูกนิยามเป็นน้ำหนักน้อยสุดของ operation เหล่านี้ เรายังมี Pauli operation
ที่ทำให้เกิด syndrome อื่น และเราสามารถพิจารณาแต่ละ syndrome ได้ แต่ตรงนี้เราแค่สมมติว่า
syndrome S ปรากฏขึ้น สมมติว่า E เป็น error ใน
หมวดนี้ที่มีน้ำหนักน้อยกว่าครึ่งหนึ่งของ distance D เราไม่รู้ว่านี่
จำเป็นต้องเป็น Pauli operation น้ำหนักน้อยสุดในวงกลมนี้ ดังนั้นให้ C เป็น operation น้ำหนักน้อยสุดในเซตนี้ หรือตัวใดตัวหนึ่งในกรณีที่เท่ากัน
ดังนั้น C อาจเท่ากับ E หรืออาจไม่ก็ได้ แต่เพราะ C มี
น้ำหนักน้อยสุด มันจะมีน้ำหนักมากกว่า E ไม่ได้ เพราะ C ก็อยู่ในเซต
และมีน้ำหนักน้อยสุด ดังนั้น correction operation C ต้องมีน้ำหนักน้อยกว่าครึ่งหนึ่งของ
D แล้วจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้าเราใช้ correction C กับ state หลังจาก error E
เกิด คำตอบคือ state ที่ได้คือ C คูณ E คูณกับ encoding เดิม เพราะเรา
คูณด้วย E ก่อน นั่นคือ error แล้วคูณด้วย C เพื่อพยายามแก้ไข และผลคูณนี้ต้องอยู่ใน
stabilizer หรือเป็นสัดส่วนของ stabilizer element และนี่คือเหตุผล อันดับแรก เพราะ E กับ C ให้เรา
syndrome เดียวกัน C คูณ E ต้องให้ syndrome บวกหนึ่งทั้งหมด เพราะสำหรับ
stabilizer generator ที่กำหนด C กับ E ทั้งคู่ commute กับ generator นั้น หรือทั้งคู่ anticommute ต้องเหมือนกัน
สำหรับทั้งคู่ เพราะ syndrome เดียวกัน และถ้าคิดสักครู่ มันบอกว่า C คูณ E ต้อง
commute กับ stabilizer generator ทั้งหมด และสุดท้าย C คูณ E ต้อง
อยู่ใน stabilizer เพราะน้ำหนักของมันไม่สามารถมากกว่าผลรวมของน้ำหนัก C กับ E ดังนั้นน้ำหนัก
ของมันน้อยกว่า D อย่างเคร่งครัด และนี่หมายความว่าเราแก้ไข E สำเร็จ เพราะการใช้ E แล้วตามด้วย C ไม่ทำอะไรกับ
code space เลย นั่นดีมาก แต่มีปัญหาอยู่อย่างหนึ่ง คือสำหรับ stabilizer
code โดยทั่วไป มันเป็นปัญหาที่ยากในเชิง computation ที่จะคำนวณ operation น้ำหนักน้อยสุดที่ทำให้เกิด syndrome
ที่กำหนด และจริงๆ มันเป็นจริงแม้แต่สำหรับ code แบบ classical ซึ่งในบริบทนี้เราสามารถคิดว่าเป็น stabilizer code
ที่มีแค่ identity matrix กับ Pauli Z matrix เป็น tensor factor ใน stabilizer
generator ดังนั้นไม่เหมือนขั้นตอน encoding Clifford operation ไม่ได้มาช่วยเราคราวนี้ และทางแก้ที่สมเหตุสมผล
เดียวคือเลือก code เฉพาะที่สามารถคำนวณ correction ที่ดีได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ และไม่มีสูตรสำเร็จสำหรับ
เรื่องนี้ พูดง่ายๆ การคิดค้น stabilizer code แบบนี้เป็นส่วนหนึ่งของศิลปะ
ของการออกแบบ quantum code และนั่นเป็นจุดที่ดีในการหยุดสำหรับบทเรียนนี้ หวังว่าจะมาร่วมฟัง
บทเรียนถัดไป ซึ่งเราจะดู quantum code construction เฉพาะบางอัน รวมถึง code ที่แสดงให้เห็นศิลปะของการออกแบบ quantum code
ในแบบที่น่าตื่นเต้นมาก บายตอนนี้นะ